Speaker 1: I don't want to spend a lot of time on
this, but I do want to let you know that this guy,
Christopher Key, who is now known for injecting
urine for COVID, he's been arrested. This is the
guy who I previously told you was recommending
people drink urine. And then last week started
recommending people inject urine. He has been
arrested. Organizers tasked with putting on
a Jacksonville, Florida, conference headlined by
COVID troopers. Robert Malone and Peter McCullough
had enough of anti-vaxxer Christopher Key's
shenanigans. They reported the vaccine police
leader to police as a trespasser, which sent him
back to jail again, where he is now awaiting a
preliminary hearing. Key could be heard on video
berating an organizer of the far right gathering
after he claimed that she mandated he move his
car off a sidewalk. Is that a sidewalk? Is that
the same thing? Then he claimed he went to the.
Building at the Take Action for Freedom tour to
take a tinkle. And that led to police being
called. He said he was being asked to leave.
An unidentified gathering organizer said to
the officer that key was causing a disturbance.
You've caused a big disturbance key apparently
still wouldn't leave after being given a trespass
warning, and then he was indeed arrested. Now
what's fascinating is he wasn't arrested for
injecting urine that apparently is legal. As long
as you do it to yourself, I guess. I mean, it's
not a good idea. It's dangerous if you hit it. If
you hit a vein, it can be very, very bad, but just
trespassing. And again, what is fascinating to me
about this stuff is I've said, before you look at
flat-Earth, you put two flat-Earthers in a room
together. They both agree the earth is flat,
but for conflicting reasons. One will say, Well,
here's the proof that the Earth is flat and the
other will say, no, that can't be true, because
here's my proof and it directly conflicts with it.
These anti-vaxx and sort of like COVID alternative
treatment people, they are often in conflict about
why the vaccines are bad or about what you
should do instead. And you've got a big group of
people who talks about zinc and ivermectin and
hydroxychloroquine, et cetera. They don't want
anybody injecting urine. They agree the vaccines
are bad, but they're like, inject urine. No,
that doesn't make any sense. Then you've got
the drink and nebulizer and inject urine people
who are like zinc. No way in hell, zinke's. You
put heavy metal. You know who the hell knows they
conflict with each other. These people are all
bonkers. They're still holding conferences. But
it's at least funny that Christopher
Key ended up getting himself arrested,
maybe for attention. But I don't really know what
the end game is if he's trying to get attention